blacks are pawn up but white gets the
pawn back right now now the threat is as
I told you Knight takes Knight pawn
takes Knight Bishop takes pawn check but
that's easily defended what's the
obvious way of detecting the knight on
c6 welcome to the nice opening class
we're covering basic chess open when you
learn chess for the first time it's
recommended that both that you start
with this move where each player plays a
pawn in front of the King up two squares
notice how the pawns block each other
white White's territory is the first
four rows and blacks territory or the
next four rows now objectively white
gets to move first so he has the first
move advantage he he has a piece out
before black black is there for the
defender what black tries to do is to
keep white from coming in his territory
with too many pieces then white might be
able to win a pawn or something or a
piece or something so the basic idea in
an opening is you only make a few pawn
moves to establish a position in the
center of the board that's why the pawn
in front of the king or the Queen are
the most popular moves and you always do
the two moves if you're white you would
be wasting a move if you only move the
pawn up to King three so you want as
that pawn moves up it gives you squares
behind it for your pieces to move into
and it blocks the black pawn and keeps
it from moving
now the the pawn on e4 they of course
pawns take diagonally so the pawn on e4
covers the d5 square in the f5 square
those two white squares the most
important squares in the chessboard or
the four Center squares and the next
most important are the surroundings
squares around the four Center squares
they're called the near center squares a
lot of the strategy in chess is that the
person who tries who's most successful
in chess controls more squares with his
pieces than his opponent now the way you
control more squares you have to move
your knights bishops Queens and rooks
out into the middle of the board where
they can impact squares on white side of
the board and also white wants to impact
squares on black side of the board so
for example take the the White Knight
its traditional with this move that the
next move for white is to play the
knight to f3 so anyway that night
attacks the pawn on e5 which is
undefended it forces black to defend the
pawn the standard way is to bring the
knight to c6 and capital n c6 so another
opening principle I could have moved
this Knight to c3 right but I chose to
move the knight to f3
well what opening principal told me to
move the knight to f3 if you have a
choice between two good oak moves and
one as a threat and one doesn't
you pick the move that has a threat
Knight here doesn't threaten anything
Knight their threatens a pawn forces
black to make a defensive move if you
make attacking moves and force your
opponent to defend like in football the
defense doesn't
or that many foot goals right touchdowns
they don't make that many touchdowns in
chess if you keep your opponent on the
defensive he can't check meet you
he can't beat you and the first move and
making threats and making your opponent
be defensive that's called the
initiative in chess meaning that you are
initiating the aggressive action and
your opponent is responding to it so one
chest starts thought you don't have a
winning advantage you have the first
move advantage and you try to maintain
as long as you can by continuously
looking for threats as you bring your
pieces up sometimes there are no threats
to be made but then you figure out what
what piece goes to the best square in
the shortest amount of time and there
may be no threat at all it only comes in
you make the threat if you have a choice
between a move with a threat or a move
without a threat okay anyway there's no
great threat here so we're going through
the Bishop to c4 line now the there's
two main lines for this Bishop Bishop
here leads to the Italian game or the
two knights we're doing the two Knights
defense
who knows what Bishop here is what's the
name of Bishop here Spanish game or the
Rory Lopez Ruy Lopez named after a
Spanish Bishop from 1700s or something
who popularized it they're both good
moves and they're played today they've
been played for 200 250 years by
grandmasters so pawn Knight Bishop you
see I got a pawn in two pieces out my
opponent has the pawn and a piece so
black doesn't fall behind in development
he has to develop a piece he has two
reasonable possibilities he can bring
the knight here and attack this Pau
which is undefended or he can move that
bishop up here that's a good development
move and it's comparable with what white
did if he brings the bishop here that's
called the Italian opening if he brings
the knight here it's called the two
Knights defense after black moving his
two Knights up simple as that
they're both perfectly valid and it's a
matter of choice
whichever way you like to play it and I
play both of them just for variety but
we're going to go over the knight one
because that's our subject tonight now I
told you why it's attacking now in this
case black makes an attacking move on an
undefended pawn so blacks move is called
a counter attack white was the initial
aggressor now black is counter attacking
this the knight to f6 is a counter
attack defense whereas the Bishop to c5
which threatens nothing it's just a good
development move that's another standard
but it's not a counter attack it's just
a good developing move okay so white has
some choices he could bring the knight
here from that would be capital end to
c3 from here it protects the pawn which
is attacked and in the future it can hop
up here to the center they'd have to he
has to protect this pawn first by maybe
putting the pawn here and the pawns to
link up it's called a pawn chain they
protect this pawn protects this pawn and
protects this pawn pawn chains are very
strong pawn structures defensively this
is a very strong defensive structure
white however wants to be more
aggressive he doesn't care to have a
strong defensive structure as the
he's going to be aggressive an attack
black centre so in this line
he plays pawn the Queen for now the pawn
is protected by the knight and queen and
this pawn the text of the pawn on e5 and
the knight so black the the standard
move is pawn takes pawn and if white
wants to he can win the pawn back with
Knight takes pawn and if Knight takes
Knight the Queen takes Knight so he's
got it covered
this pawn is protected twice it's
attacked twice that's all you need to
defend if it was attacked three times
say that Bishop was here then this pawn
would be lost and pawn here would be a
blunder so blacks move is pawn takes
now what did white get for this moving
the pawn up number one he got this
bishop to come out at what the pawn was
here blocking the bishop now the bishop
can move out number two the pawn that
was here blocking this pawn no longer
blocks the pawn this bond can move up
and attack the knight that's number two
number three the pond was blocking the
Queen now it's up here when this Knight
takes the pawn the queen has an open
line up the middle of the board this is
called the a file
they're not just columns what they're
called files and because this is the
Queen file it's called the D file so
white gets a lot with this move black
has an adequate defense though and I'll
show it to you white doesn't take the
pawn he prefers to move the pawn up and
to attack the knight on f6 now the
question I would throw out to the
audience is what is blacks best move
here on the surface say you have a
appearances in chess it's like a show
and a play you see the stage or like a
mystery play what you see on the stage
is the surface it's it's what appears
but yes you know they're in a mystery
there are things happening behind the
scenes somebody gets killed somebody
gets poisoned it's beneath the surface
so in chess you have what's apparent on
the surface of the chessboard and in
this case what's apparent is that pawn
is attacking the knight and the natural
reaction is by golly I got to move the
knight that's the first reaction for
black it may not be the right reaction
so in chess you have to look a few moves
ahead you have to consider all the
possible alternative moves because you
may if you if you made a gut reaction
that your Knights attack and you moved
it that would be an incorrect move you
have to look beneath the surface see
what other alternative moves there are
and in this case I'll point out one
that's better than moving the knight so
here's how you look for an alternative
move the knight is threatened
either move it or you lose it but you
don't if you can make a threat just as
powerful as his threat White's
threatening to win a knight if you can
make a threat to win a knight or Bishop
then the threats are equal and opposite
that leads us to consider not moving the
knight remember I told you if you move
the knight twice in the opening you it's
a waste of time you try to develop your
pieces and pawns it turns out there's an
alternative move to moving the knight
and you attack that bishop by moving the
pawn in front of the Queen two squares
see how the pawns protected by the
knight and the Queen and if white takes
the knight black takes the bishop now
this pawn can take that pawn not a
problem our Bishop takes the pawn and
then our Bishop is on a good square
pointing to the center and the King can
castle and the bishop it's still it's
almost like three pawns
there's the pawn of Bishop and a pawn
but the bishop guards the same squares
the pawn does it's perfectly safe for
black turns out that it's a mistake for
white to take the knight with the pawn
it helps black wait a minute
let me go back right here now what are
you saying well then the knight on f3
would take the knight and I would win a
knight which is worth three pawns for
one pawn and black would be in effect
two pawns down and remember Grandmaster
wins usually one pawn up even a lowly
master can win almost every game if he's
two pawns up so that would be a gross
blunder for you to take that pot with
the night you would earn yourself two
question marks and a lost Chesky so pawn
the Queen for is much better or d5 is
the algebraic pawn the queen forced the
other notation see how the pawn attacks
to the bishop now you know you can do
when the pawns on the fifth row and the
black pawn moves past it if the
blackbaud moved here white could take
the pawn right there's a rule on chess
if the pawn moves - and this one's on
the fifth White has the option of taking
the pawn as if it had only moved one
square that's the French term pawn takes
pawn and passat which
in passing the black pawn passes the
white pawn on the fifth row it only
comes into play where the pawn moves two
squares instead of one this guy has the
option of taking the pawn as if black
had moved at one square so I could take
the pawn and there would be no threat on
my bishop right because this would be
gone my pawn would be here right but if
I take the pawn and my pawns here I'm
not attacking the knight am i and he
could take his bishop that hasn't moved
and take my pawn so I help him develop
his bishop and his next move he castles
King side and he takes over he's more
has more pieces out than I do and blacks
better so pawn takes pawn and passant is
a blunder not a huge blunder let's just
say it's a bad move the right move since
I can't take the pawn and taking the
knight doesn't work I have to move the
bishop there's only one reasonable move
for the bishop is to move here and pin
the night
the knight defends this pawn and my
Knights gonna take the pawn with the
bishop here I'm gonna throw it Knight
takes Knight pawn takes Knight Bishop
takes pawn check attacking the king and
the rook that's gonna be my threat now
he can defend it but that's still my
best move so that's why white plays the
bishop and pins the knight
now that renews the threat of pawn takes
Knight there no other threats black can
make black has to move the knight now
I'm going to leave it up to the audience
to tell me where that Knight should go
any opinions
look at each possible square and
determine which one remember the center
squares are the important ones you could
retreat back to your starting square on
g8 you could retreat in front of the
Queen on d7 if you go in front of the
Queen you block the Queen and the bishop
on white squares don't you that would be
a terrible move if you moved your knight
back to g8 word started we're trying to
develop our pieces not undeveloped them
right so we tweeted in the night to g8
is another terrible move somewhat lust
terrible but not the best move is Knight
to g4 it doesn't threaten anything
because she can't do tonight takes pawn
he does Knight takes Knight and your
knight spin so Knight to g4 doesn't
threaten anything and I can attack the
knight on g4 with my work pawn and pawn
up he has to retreat the knight to h6
right in front of the pawn in front of
the rook and then this Bishop which
hasn't moved takes the knight and that
pawn on g7 that destroys black's pawn
structure he has to weak double pawns
and that Knight moved one two three
times right three moves how many times
does the bishop move to take the knight
one that gives me three moves four black
one for me I have a to move advantage I
just got in chess that's that that's
called time time advantage that Knight
to g4 is the terrible move there's only
one good move notice there's a nice
center square right here protected by a
pawn and no pawns can attack the knight
the only problem that could attack the
knight is this pawn but it's blocked so
it can't attack the knight and even if
it did
the knight could retreat over here so
the only move is to bring the knight to
the center of the board
now that's blacks best piece it just
invaded White's fourth row didn't it
now White has the pawn on his fifth row
that invaded blacks fourth row
it's defended by the knight so it's
still kind of even black has a knight
invading White's territory white is a
pawn
invading black blacks upon up but white
gets the pawn back right now
now the threat is as I told you Knight
takes Knight pawn takes Knight Bishop
takes pawn check but that's easily
defended what's the obvious way of
detecting the knight on c6 the Black
Knight it's blacks move who wouldn't the
audience would like to give us the
obvious protect D move
yeah and that's a standard and good move
I thought it was the only move in this
position for 50 years but when I bought
this new book as I teach I teach young
people just classes and I thought I
oughta
bone up on my openings he comes up with
a different move so that is the obvious
move and it's played quite frequently
and it's perfectly good it turns out
there's a counter-attack so the
defensive move was just the one he just
said is she simply protected the knight
and you break the pin that's perfectly
good it also turns out there's another
good move remember you can defend or you
can counter-attack there's a hidden
resource here black can counter-attack
and he plays here with his Bishop
attacking the knight now it looks like
simply Knight takes Knight pawn takes
Knight Bishop takes pawn check King
moves Bishop takes rook black must have
been out of his mind he just lost a rook
that's the surface in chess you have to
look a few moves beyond that notice that
the black bishop that went to c5 and the
knight are attacking this pawn here when
this Knight goes here pawn here Bishop
takes pawn check the king over Bishop
takes rook this bishop line is open
black does Bishop takes pawn check
forcing the King to move let's say the
King moves here see this white bishop
here this pawn is gone right it will
came here and the bishop is here that
Bishop comes here checking the King the
King moves in the corner blocks the row
can't network can't get out and then the
Queen takes the bishop now white did get
a rook for a bishop but black got some
pawns and has White's King stuck in a
very bad spot that's called more than
adequate compensation black is winning
that game so Bishop to c5 is a hidden
resource that I didn't know about and
I've been playing chess for 50 years but
it's in that book it turns out this
resource has been known since 1934 not
to me but grandmasters knew about it
there was a a world champion contender
in 1934 named Paul Karras from Estonia
he was in the top 10 not when he played
this game he was playing postal chess as
a younger guy he became a top 10 player
this is his game so he knew about it in
1934 anyway white makes a dubious move
here castles looks like a fine move it
gets the King safety the rook protects
the f2 pawn which is being a tip
potentially attacked by the knight and
Bishop as I told you the pride will go
see the problem now after castling white
does threaten Knight takes pawn
Bishop takes pawn check and Bishop takes
rook so that's the true threat Black's
not so much worried about losing one
pawn so blacks gives up the pawn and
just Casas white wins the pawn and it's
threatening the rook and the Queen and
Bishop threaten this pawn and once they
take this pawn they threaten the knight
looks like looks like black might be in
some trouble so if the rook moves here
so the bishop doesn't take it the Queen
can take the pawn threatening to take
the knight
and if Queen takes Queen Bishop takes
and the bishop threatens the knight but
there's a again there's a hidden
resource the surface this Bishop attacks
the rook black thinks I gotta move the
work and if you do your initial reaction
without thinking about your other
possible moves moving the rook is a
mistake it turns out again there's a
counter-attack that Bishop is attacking
your work your Bishop can attack that
work so the right move is Bishop here
you don't waste time moving the rook
without a threat you make a counter
threat and the Queen can now if the
bishop takes erect later on the Queen
can take the bishop plus you get that
rook
this is fully equal this is better for
black white is losing his first move
advantage
anyway white takes the rook and black
takes the rook now he took the rook the
rook was defending the pond
now black threatens Knight takes pawn
protected by the bishop attacking the
Queen and if the Queen moves the knight
can move somewhere with the discovered
check on the King white doesn't like
that he doesn't nor does he that like
Bishop takes pawn check nor does he like
the bishop retreating and then Bishop
takes pawn check so he's going to stop
Bishop takes pawn check he makes a gross
blunder that loses the game rapidly he
makes the Bishop to e3 on the surface it
looks good the bishop protects the pawn
stops the threat so what if they trade
that's what it looks like on the surface
turns out this is the wrong move his
best move and black still better would
have been just
King takes bishop then there would be no
check here because the King has moved to
a white square anyway
white made a bad move so now black can
weaken the pawns around the King with
Bishop takes see how the pond was here
there were three pawns in a row
protected by the King
now the pawns up here this pawn and this
pawn are on black squares they're
undefended that Queen can come here
threaten Queen takes pawn check and
Queen takes this pawn and the knight if
he comes here with check and if the King
goes here the night comes down here with
check attacking the Queen and King
White's in very serious trouble now
white is thinking well here's what
White's thinking I took the rook
he took my rook I moved the bishop here
he took here I took here it's blacks
move black will take the bishop with the
Queen and I get that bishop that's what
White's thinking I'm okay that's what
the surface is there's a hidden move for
black blacks gonna lose this bishop no
matter what he does right and whites
gonna lose that Bishop it's blacks move
if you're gonna lose the piece why give
it away cheaply if you can capture
something with that piece you should do
it when you have a piece that you're
gonna lose it's called a desperado from
Western terms that but you can throw
that bishop and and take something
because you're gonna lose it anyway so
the correct move is not Queen takes
bishop it's to take the pawn and if the
King takes the pawn then you could take
the bishop and you won a pawn you see
but there's even a there's even a more
hideous problem for
if king takes bishop you don't take this
bishop the queen comes here checking the
cave now the queen is here and the
knight here they're attacking the little
king and there's only a there's only one
pawn the hide behind the check is here
if he goes here he's wedged in the
corner and the queen guards all these
squares the knight drops down here
checkmate
if it wasn't checkmate he'd win the
Queen but he doesn't even need that
that's the checkmate so if the King
takes Queen check the King has to go
here then there's a queen check here and
the King goes here and the Queen comes
down here Chuck and the King goes up
here you think the King belongs up here
in the middle of the board Black has a
totally won game so white seat now white
is seized his problem he didn't see it
three or four moves ago he thought he
was okay he has to move the Queen here
to guard against this check so that's
what he does now white is hoping okay I
lost the pawn but now he'll take the
bishop I got the check covered and then
I take the bishop with the queen or the
king and I lost a pawn but at least my
pieces are even and I still got two four
six two there's still six pawns versus
Ponce's White was a pawn up so white
thinks he can get a draw well remember
this little guy still a desperado now he
can't take anything but this White Queen
wants to stop the check here right this
little guy can move here and attack the
Queen draw in the Queen back here away
from here and then the black Queen can
come up here in check white didn't see
that Paul Karras saw that but he was a
top 10 player in the world so he attacks
the Queen now the Queen has to take it
and the Queen comes up with check I told
you the King can't go in the corner this
is still a checkmate so he goes over
here and now we get the bishop not with
the Queen with the rook now let's look
at our position this rook can't move
it's wedged behind the pawn and the
night
this Knight can't go here Knight takes
Knight check this is not a good score
fort Knight takes Knight and he gets
weak double pawns and if he goes up here
he's on the side of the board he can't
go here because of this pawn he's out of
play on the side of the board but at
least the work had come over
in the meantime black can bring the rook
here here an attack or here here Plus
black is threatening to win this pawn
Queen takes pawn as a threat white
resigns there's no defense
what happened was white let black get
ahead with more pieces out see how he
has a pawn a knight McQueen three pieces
he's only got one the pawns in front of
his King have been destroyed white
doesn't have a chance plus blacks
threatening to win this then he'll be
have two four five against six he'll be
a pawn up and a grandmaster even if
white had better pieces a grandmaster
could win a pawn up this is in this case
black is going to get the pawn and have
a strong attack after Queen takes pawn
he'll threaten Queen takes pawn down
here so White's totally lost in resigns
and this is an important thing to know
so I didn't know about it so getting
back to this position when I played many
speed chess games and I always played
the Bishop to d7 line I never dreamed I
could get away with the counter-attack
but now I'm going to play Bishop to c5
what turns out that white mishandled
this opening right here White Castle
that's his fatal mistake the move that
would have held an even position for
white is a developing move that's not
really surprising he could have moved
his Bishop here see how it protects the
knight on d4 and protects the pawn on f2
and renews the threat of Knight takes
Knight pawn takes Knight Bishop takes
pawn check winning the black rook that's
the right move and we'll run through
that real quick this is another game
played later on and I guess the players
knew the right way to play so again I
just run through it
they played a little different order
remember the bishop came out and then
the night game to f6 he's playing pawn
to Queen four early but it's going to
transpose right here and then the knight
and we're in the same position pawn up
pawn up pin the knight Knight up Knight
takes pawn our good move Bishop c5 but
now the right move for white protecting
everything black castles he still gives
up the pawn but there's no check Bishop
takes the pawn oh wait a minute right
here you can't do Bishop takes pawn
because black would do Bishop takes pawn
takes and it's starting to look like
that other game isn't it with a pawn
here and the Queen here check white
taking that pawn this pawn would be a
blunder cuz when he has to do he has to
take the bishop first so he takes the
bishop and now the knight on the center
gets drawn back to Black's fourth row
when he recaptures you see so that night
here is not nearly as threatening as it
was here attacking here back here and
you see these pawns are still in front
the King's gonna Castle and have a nice
wall pawns in front of him
there's no pawn up here black White's
nice and safe this time so white can
take the pawn now though there's no
bishop here on the rook there's no Rick
here he has to move the rook
out of the way of the bishop that gives
us time to take this pawn with the Queen
and right now white is two pawns up but
black has a counter-attack that rook is
can take this pawn and his King has in
Castle blacks castle White has the Queen
and Bishop
Black has the night ruck and queen but
he has a problem his Knights threatened
and white might trade Queens and if
black does Queen takes Queen then Bishop
takes well black doesn't want to trade
Queens these two pawns down if your two
pawns down you want to attack your enemy
pawns and get some of those pawns back
you want to keep the game complicated so
he needs to protect the knight he can't
move the knight white could take the
Queen the right move is the Queen moves
up to the black square protecting the
knight and making way for the work to
come over here can drive the Queen away
from the middle of the board white
castles he gets his phone back now
blacks only one pawn down and these
three pawns are weak black's gonna get
another pawn White's behind in
development now so he brings his Knight
out as I told you black brings this rook
over and forces the Queen back now black
has a good move with the knight he
retreats here but he's going to come up
here attack the Queen and Bishop and the
Queen can protect the bishop he doesn't
win the bishop but he'll take the bishop
and the Queen comes here and then the
bishop will come here attacking the
Queen and starting an attack down toward
the white King that's called a
counter-attack
what white sees this so he's gonna he
sees that there's only one black work
defending the back row he's going to
take his rook that's not doing anything
move it here and swap out the black rook
that will reduce black's attacking
chances so he goes here black carries
out his knight fork the Queen has to
move he takes the bishop and as I said
the bishop comes up attacking the Queen
the work here protects the bishop the
Queen moves now black would like
to do Queen takes pawn which is
undefended but then it would be Rick
takes for a checkmate the Queen is
defending the rook the rook needs to
move he moves over now the threat is
Queen takes pawn winning the game White
is going to lose that pawn it's a pawn
desperado he moves it up to trip force
the trade of Queens Queen takes Queen
takes you can't do rook takes because
the rook down checkmate so you have to
take with the pond so White gave up a
pawn but he messed up black's pawn
structure and this pawn blocks the rook
keeps it from coming down that's very
important and this rook can come up and
attack these pawns maybe you may be in
that see how this rook and the bishop
are on the same line this Rick threatens
to this pond White is going to take this
rook which is doing nothing that's
behind a pawn move it here and if the
rook move takes the pawn he gets the
bishop and if the rook takes here this
Rick takes back threatening the bishop
winning and white another move this is a
good move by white leads to an even
position black takes the pawn bishop but
now they agreed to a draw in view of
rook takes knight black gets white gets
that pawn and black moves up here pawns
are even four pawns they both have two
rooks
and it's completely even ending so they
agree to a draw that's how that's the
correct way white can hold the position
but not win it against the Bishop to c5
line well the interesting thing is now
that we know
remember this all started out because
white aggressively moved the pawn up
here leading to all these trades and the
but it led to an even game didn't it
this aggressive move well guess what the
grandmasters are doing now they're not
playing that move anymore they know it's
a draw
now what they're doing they're do what
they're doing is well let me back up
first you get the bishop out and then
the knight comes out so there's our two
Knights
now they don't move two squares they
move one square they're being
conservative they build a strong center
with that pawn chain see how the bishops
outside the pawn chain it's not blocked
by the white pawns and White's going to
slowly build up an attack and not allow
the trade of pawns and pieces which lead
to equality this is how they're playing
it now it's much more complicated and
that's what we'll go through next week
[Music]